what's going on guys as you can probably
tell by the thumbnail and the title of
this video
today we're going to be examining the
hypothetical child of azuka midoriya and
ochako uraraka i actually made this
character up for a totally different
idea i'm working on
about who could be the 10th user of one
for all but as i began to flesh her
quirk out in my head
i realized she was probably worthy of
having her own quick video
this is the first time i've done a
totally original character before
so make sure you smash that like button
if this is something you would like to
see more of
also a quick update i now have new
emotes on the youtube channel
which can be used in the comments of my
videos whether you're on mobile or
desktop
my favorite one is probably the deku
crying one or the one of me reading
manga
but yeah you can get access to these by
just hitting the join button on my
channel
and becoming a member you'll be
supporting me personally if you do
and once more people join then i can
start adding new emojis
almost immediately okay so i decided to
call this character nori uraraka which
is a bit of a tongue twister to say out
loud
and the sensible reason she didn't take
madoria's last name was
for safety reasons and i'll elaborate on
that more in the next video about this
the name nori is a respectful reference
to all might whose real name was
toshinoriyagi
i personally do not see any future in
which deku has children
and doesn't name at least one of them
after all might in some way
it just has to happen anyway she is
technically the oldest child of deku's
family
as she was born 15 minutes before her
twin brother
due to the power of one for all being
public knowledge in the future
nori had a very protective and private
upbringing with her existence as the
daughter of the number one hero
being mostly unknown in the future the
threat of the quirk singularity is very
real
and quirks are becoming more and more
uncontrollable despite that
the luxury of proper quirk training is
still only given to those who want to be
heroes
after nori had a serious accident
involving her power
deku decided that she had to go to ua in
order to get the correct training
and avoid being a danger to society just
before we get into her quirk
i should mention that she carries around
this hyper density seal
as a support item and we've previously
seen these used by sir naitai in the
past
but we'll get into how nori uses this
once we explain her ability
her quirk is called gravity shift and it
has clear elements of her mother's zero
gravity power
and her grandmother's telekinetic
ability to begin
nori can use telekinesis to attract
people or objects towards her
with varying degrees of speed small
objects like a spoon
could be drawn towards her in seconds
whereas heavy objects like people or
cars
would be attracted in a much more slow
and controlled manner
depending on the weight her maximum
limit is 4 tons
and if she was to pull anything heavier
than that then you guessed it
the telekinetic pull works over a very
long range as long as she can see
something
she can pull it towards her but the
downside is that you know like i said
she has to see it first she couldn't
pull something on the other side of a
concrete wall because she can't see
through it
whereas she could pull something through
a window as long as that object or
person
remains visible to her the other
drawback is that her telekinesis can be
stopped completely
if she takes enough damage this is
similar to how seji's quirk operates
in that his victims can't escape until
he takes one too many hits
moving on once something is within
touching distance
then the pads on nori's fingers come
into play which is when she can activate
her true powers
after making contact with any of her
fingertips she can manipulate the
intensity of gravity
on a particular thing purely as an
example if she was to touch enosa with
one of her fingers
she could decide to multiply the
gravitational pull on his head
to a higher intensity than usual in this
example let's say she multiplies the
effect of gravity
by a hundred times this would result in
his head violently slamming into the
ground
and you know possibly killing him she
wouldn't go this far but it just shows
you how scary the power could be
another application might be multiplying
the gravitational pull
on someone's feet until they have no
choice but to start moving around like
this
or you could use it on a vehicle to stop
someone from escaping she could easily
restrain a person for 20 minutes with no
problem
whereas if she was to restrain a you
know a vehicle like i said
that would take a lot more effort and
she would start to feel sick a lot
quicker
similar to ochako nori could dial back
the effects of her quirk
and decide to nullify gravity instead
which causes weightlessness and allows
things to float
the effect only wears off if she decides
to press her fingertips together
and her current weight limit when doing
this is 4 tons
talking about support items now nori
carries this high density seal
which weighs 5 kilograms in total by
throwing this item at the correct angle
she can activate gravity shift just as
it leaves her fingertips
which will cause the seal to hit someone
with increased momentum
and because of the effect of gravity the
weight begins to increase until it can
floor someone completely
as a result when you take everything
into account she does have a lot of
options
she can pull people towards her from a
distance and then when she touches that
person
she can make them float or she can
restrain them with intense gravity
she can also turn her support item from
a small weight
into a killing machine and she can use
her telekinesis
to call it back like thor's hammer one
thing i forgot to mention was that she
can use the floating ability on herself
so if she touches her own body then she
can float just like ochako does
um i think that she can float easier
without throwing up straight away
but eventually you know if she does it
for long enough she will throw up
hopefully this video was a good
introduction to this character
and make sure to subscribe and turn on
notifications so you don't miss my
upcoming video
and it will be in a similar style to my
previous next generation videos
remember you can become a member and
support the channel just by going on
your laptop or
computer and then clicking the join
button by doing this you are not only
supporting me
but you get access to exclusive posts
for members only in the community tab
and obviously the emojis which you can
use in the comments of any one of my
videos
be sure to check it out and until the
next one peace out